the kind of framework or Philosophy for
this this Challenge and trying to
simplify it was test intervene retest
we're really speaking to four Key
Systems of the body they are the
cardiovascular system metabolic system
muscular skeletal system and emotional
health so we had a long laundry list of
things that you can measure to act as a
window into how those systems are
operating and we were able to reduce
that very long laundry list down to what
we've called the 10 truths we're going
to test the 10 truths at the beginning
and from there we can intervene with
some degree of specificity what
protocols can shift specific biomarkers
in the right direction and then
afterwards we retest everything and we
can see how that longevity score has
shifted